Constantemente me encuentro muy
distraído durante el día.   ¿
Cómo puedo
concentrarme más en lo que estoy haciendo?  Simplemente me
aburro y
[risas]
Así que, honestamente, lo pensé, ¿debería
tomar Adderall
o algo así?  Como que realmente no sé
[risas] o sea
Honestamente creo que es creo que es
eliminación más que cualquier otra cosa.  Entonces, es, es, quiero decir,
Jerry Seinfeld dijo
esto y realmente me gusta en términos
de cómo tenía su estructura de escritura porque
escribía durante 2 horas al día todos los días, se
encerraba en una habitación
donde no tenía nada más que un bloc de papel
y un lápiz y decía que no tenía que
escribir pero no podía hacer nada
más.
Creo que es como estar
en una computadora, de repente pienso: "
Oh, ¿qué pasa con esta cosa aleatoria en la
vida?", y luego me meto en un
laberinto de ideas, y es como: "Ya
sabes, es asignación de recursos".
Fundamentalmente, este es el microcosmos
del emprendimiento: ¿puedes
manejarlo? Si no puedes administrar tu
tiempo,
nunca ganarás dinero.
Como si fuera lo único que todos
aquí tienen por igual.  Y así, en
definitiva, la rapidez con la que avanzamos en la vida
depende de la eficiencia con la que la gestionamos
.